weltraumtourismus geht es jetzt auch
schon los zahlreiche unternehmen wollen
ja reisen in den weltraum anbieten aber
kommen nicht so richtig aus den pötten
jetzt soll es aber schon 2018 so weit
sein und mit diesem anbieter hat im
moment wohl glaube ich keiner gerechnet
also mehr dazu jetzt herzlich willkommen
die premiere der weltraumtourismus
hätten wir ja eigentlich schon längst
erleben sollen ja stimmt booster
gradient war verkündete einst dass die
erste weltraumtourismus flüge bereits
2016 möglich sein naja ganz vaters doch
nicht geklappt die ersten flüge sind
wohl erst gegen ende dieses jahrzehnts
möglich prüfen von virgin galactic das
unternehmen von richard branson
der weg vom flughafen spaceport america
der ist ja schon seit sechs jahren
fertig und weltraumflüge pustekuchen
seit dem schweren unfall bei einem
testflug gerät das unternehmen immer
mehr in verzug werden dort weitere tests
bügel gemacht aber es scheint doch nicht
so einfach zu sein zu rüsten in den
weltraum zu bringen aber jetzt ist eine
bombe geplatzt das von ihnen maske
gründete raumfahrtunternehmen spacex hat
jetzt wohl alle mal so eben recht
überholter privatunternehmen wird jetzt
wohl die ersten weltraumtouristen in
einem ersten reinen beruf muss flug ins
weltall bringen und jetzt kommt es aber
nicht irgendwo hin
ihnen macht wie die touristen zum mond
schicken
zitat wie rückseite für 96 bei sechs
abrutschte frei zu freizügig und sexy so
die worte von patrick rizzo nächstes
jahr mit einem flug rund um den mond los
und das auch noch für otto
normalverbraucher otto normalverbraucher
wohl wahrscheinlich eher nicht das ganze
wird nämlich eine stange geld kosten
glaubt man früheren berechnungen für
einen flug als zur iss ins all und
250.000 dollar
und das ist eine reise in 100 kilometer
höhe über der erde mit ein paar minuten
schwerelosigkeit die reise zum mond wird
da wohl einen hauch teurer ein starter
falcon 9 rakete mit einer dragon kapsel
zur internationalen raumstation iss
kostet 54 millionen zum mond geht es mit
einer größeren rakete der falcon heavy
und der zweiten generation des dragon
raumschiff und um wen es sich bei diesen
zwei pionieren werden frei sein wurde
bisher noch nicht bekannt gegeben auf
jeden fall werden
für den ernsten bewohnern und wurf
planeten gehören einen zweistelligen
millionenbeitrag haben nicht so viele
auf der hohen kante bis im jahr 2018
dann endlich soweit sein soll müssen
noch jede menge gesundheit fitness und
viele andere messen mit den ersten
privaten mond umrunden durchgeführt
werden es wenn er wahrscheinlich nicht
die jüngsten ich bin jedenfalls sehr
gespannt auf dieses projekt möglich
gehabt aber in maskat ja schon einige
ziele erreiche man hier könnt ihr
übrigens weitere videos über
weltraumtourismus schauen und hier
könnte mehr abo aufs auge drücken und
werden wir noch einen auf die glocke
geben will der kann das natürlich auch
tun dann verpassen wir nie mehr krieg
zoom und hättet ihr lust ins all zu
fliegen und was würdet ihr dafür
ausgeben ab in die kommentare damit und
antworten bis dann bleib dran